[Applause]
waving malian flags thousands gathered
in mali's capital bamako
to protest against the former colonial
power france
[Applause]
there was even a cardboard cut out of
french president emmanuel macron which
was later set on fire
[Music]
the crowd was celebrating the expulsion
of the french ambassador
he was given 72 hours to leave after the
french foreign minister described mali's
military leaders as illegitimate and out
of control
there are thousands and thousands and
thousands of malians today who say no to
france so what the european union and
france needs to do is respect the malian
authorities they need to understand that
the authorities in charge today are the
only ones who can speak for our country
the rally was called by prominent
nationalist activist and member of the
transitional authority adama bendyara
who the european union says helped
overthrow mali's government in august
2020.
the demonstration happening on the same
day he was sanctioned by the eu for his
role in the coup
the measures include travel bans and
asset freezes and target five people
including the transitional prime
minister cho'gal maeger and members of
interim president asimi goyta's inner
circle
relations with the eu have soured since
goiter put himself in charge and reneged
on a promise to hold elections this
month the european sanctions are a sign
of rationing up the pressure but simply
follow what the africans have done
themselves i think dialogue certainly is
still an option and that's the preferred
course of action by both ecowas and the
international community but diara
described the sanctions as an honour
saying expelling the french ambassador
is only the latest step in getting rid
of paris's influence
it's an important step in the fight but
the victory must go all the way
the next step must be the departure of
french forces and then we will start to
move towards economic and monetary
sovereignty
there are about 5 000 foreign troops in
mali deployed to contain years of
insecurity in the north
they include missions from france the
wider eu and the united nations
we don't want any foreign troops in mali
they've been here for eight years now
and nothing has changed
there were russian flags in the crowd at
friday's rally russian mercenaries were
welcomed by mali's military leaders last
year and diara says he will rely on
moscow to ensure france is forced out
for good
alexia o'brien al jazeera